[Music]
there's a scene in the film
which is that's very us
where and i think bonded us we're really
connected there's something about this
film that creates
it built a lot of
real
friendships
yep a lot of eternal bonds were made
while shooting this superhero adventure
they even have staring contests i've got
this
[Music]
but the relationship that's got
everyone's attention the love triangle
between jimmy chan and game of thrones
stark brothers kit harrington and
richard madden how long were you
together 5 000 years i guess you can
call that long term i am a game of
thrones fan and i also knew kit and
richard i've known them for years we
tried to kind of you know this is a this
is a whole other story we try not to be
burdened by you know the references yeah
i think that's what marvel are really
good at at times is a little wink and a
nod to camera you know like it'd be
silly not to
the eternals diverse cast includes
marvel's first ever deaf superhero
played by lauren ridloff and kumail
nanjiani who worked out five days a week
to get in fighting form can we talk
about kumail the sex symbol we saw the
physical transformation and it was
fabulous it helps me mentally you know
that's the goal now i find that doing
some of that stuff makes me less anxious
the cast told us they're up for doing a
sequel but before that sam was starring
in house of gucci as lady gaga's partner
in crime
what are you looking forward to most
about having when everyone see you in
this space in this world
well first of all i hope they don't
recognize me because okay it's not my
most glamorous
look ever it's a small role
it was a fun role and we had a lot of
fun together